hi guys today we are going to talk about
10 things you didn't know about Bitcoin
firstly we have the mysterious creator
now in 2009 a person or a group of
people known as Satoshi Nakamoto
introduced Bitcoin to the world he
vanished off the internet in late 2010
he hasn't been heard from since
now just like his identity is chardon
mystery nobody really knows if he's even
alive or dead the only communication
people had with him we're through emails
and forums his Bitcoin wallet holds
around 980 thousand bitcoins which makes
him one of the richest people on the
planet next up we have the Satoshi now
as a sign of respect for the bitcoins
creator the smallest unit of a bitcoin
is known as a Satoshi
one Satoshi is valued at around zero
point zero zero zero zero six six nine
for u.s. dollars which is a very very
low value now to make one Bitcoin you
need approximately hundred millions Auto
she's now according to the current
Bitcoin values which fluctuates a lot to
make a dollar you need close to fifteen
thousand eight hundred satoshis losing
bitcoins losing a Bitcoin address which
is also known as your private key not
only means losing your unique
identification it also means you lose
all the bitcoins in your wallet
research shows that at least 60% of all
Bitcoin addresses are ghosts which means
a huge chunk of the population that's
using the Bitcoin network have lost
their addresses now these are the people
who have lost their addresses and have
no way to access their wallet liberland
now in April 2015 a micronation between
Croatia and Serbia known as liberland
was born now this was founded by with
jelka a politician publicist activist
and the president of liberland now the
official currency of liberland
is Bitcoin now the government took this
move believing that Bitcoin and its
underlying concepts of blockchain
provides a secure and transparent method
for recording electronic financial and
physical assets processing power the
process of mining bitcoins is expensive
process now you pay a high tool to do
this like your money your time and
electricity
now mining bitcoins requires service
that we use for that specific purpose
alone now the faster you process the
data the faster the block can be add to
the blockchain and the faster you're
rewarded with bitcoins power consumption
now
just imagine how much electricity
Ireland consumes in a year approximately
five thousand kilowatt are now how much
do you think all the Bitcoin mining
farms together consume sixty terawatt
all which is approximately 6 into 10
raise to 10 kilowatt ours which is a
large amount of power now the entire
country of Ireland which is the second
most populated city in Europe and has
eighty four thousand four hundred twenty
one kilometer square of area consumes
lesser electricity then all these farms
combined with coin ban now although
several countries around the world like
Canada and America have wholeheartedly
accept a Bitcoin there are some that
haven't countries like Bolivia Iceland
Bangladesh and Ecuador have completely
banned the usage of bitcoins there are
also countries like India of Thailand in
Iran who ask their residents to be
careful while using crypto currencies
they haven't completely banned it
however they do not accept it as a legal
tender though limited number there's a
limit to how many bitcoins can exist in
the market this number is capped at 21
million bitcoins as of this moment 17
million bitcoins are already in
circulation to give you an idea that's
almost 80% of the 21 million already
done but don't worry until 21 40 we will
still have bitcoins to mine this is
because of how miners are rewarded now -
rewarded with 12.5 bitcoins for each
block added to the blockchain and every
four years the reward reduces by half
the next having is supposed to occur in
2020 but the reward reduces to six point
two five bit cards the power of be the
terms Bitcoin with an uppercase B and
Bitcoin with the lowercase B mean two
different things
the only thing that differentiates the
two into two completely different things
is the letter B the lowercase B in
Bitcoin refers to the cryptocurrency
that is used to perform the transactions
the uppercase B in Bitcoin refers to the
ledger that stores information regarding
these transactions faster than
supercomputers the world's fastest
supercomputer the summit works at one
hundred twenty two point three better
flops which is nothing but a quadrillion
floating-point operations per second now
if you take the Bitcoin network complete
into consideration the processing power
is about eighty million seven hundred
and four thousand two hundred and ninety
Petter flops but the only thing here is
that a supercomputer can do several
different things but the only thing the
Bitcoin network
does is add blocks to the blockchain and
with that we've reached the end of the
video I hope you guys enjoyed it and
have learned something new about Bitcoin
if you feel like we've missed out on
something interesting that you've come
across let us know in the comments below
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simpler
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here